UK Ukraine's top prosecutor is preparing
to try dozens of suspected Russian war
criminals with hundreds more suspects
under investigation she says the list
includes senior Military Officers
politicians and propaganda agents some
trials have already begun thanks to
meticulous documentation on the ground
about investigating potential war crimes
could prove difficult as Russia controls
more territory a warning that our next
report contains some disturbing images
images that no one should have to see
civilians strewn across a street in
butcher
the immediate aftermath of a strike on a
maternity hospital in mariupole
a mass grave holding the unidentified
bodies of fathers mothers brothers
sisters grandparents and children
after Ukrainian Fighters pushed Russian
forces back from towns and Villages
they'd occupied evidence of atrocities
began to pile up
foreign
all being documented by human rights
groups Ukrainian officials and
journalists on the ground
now almost two months later Ukraine's
prosecutor General says investigations
are underway into well over 10 000
suspected war crimes ranging from
pillaging and looting rape and summery
execution to indiscriminate bombing of
Civilian infrastructure
the first war crimes trial concluded
last week resulting in a guilty verdict
for a 21 year old Russian soldier
charged with shooting an unarmed
Ukrainian man
foreign but in the Eastern donbass
region where the war is still being
fought tracking down evidence and
Prosecuting potential war crimes could
prove a lot more difficult
in the southern city of mariupole aerial
pitchers showed the word children dogged
outside the theater building that was
hit by Russian airstrikes in March
an Associated Press investigation
suggests as many as 600 people may have
been killed there as they sought shelter
Ukraine says Russia knew it was a
civilian Target
now Marry You Paul is in Russian hands
and an independent investigation at the
site has been impossible
exactly who and how many people died
there may never be known
in April satellite images showed
apparent Mass Graves near the city local
officials say up to 9 000 bodies could
be buried there victims of Russian
aggression they say
now Russia is focusing its assault on
the luhansk region the fear is if more
towns and cities fall under Russian
control the harder it will become to
investigate potential war crimes and
hold anyone there to account
we're joined Now by our correspondent
Terry shorts in The Hague Terry what's
the latest from Ukraine's Chief
prosecutor
I had the chance to speak with Ukraine's
prosecutor General Irina benedictova
after a press conference today here at
eurojust which is the European Union's
judicial cooperation agency also
attended by the chief prosecutor of the
international criminal court and other
National prosecutors from countries that
are helping Ukraine and the prosecutor
from Ukraine said it is so important for
her country for for the citizens the
people who are suffering those crimes
we've just seen in that piece that she
is able to provide accountability that
somebody is seen to be paying for these
crimes and we don't know yet how many of
those crimes are going to be crimes
against humanity whether they'll ever
get to the indictment to any indictments
on genocide but she explained why it's
important to move forward quickly let's
hear what she had to say
but I think not only my main goal it's
the main goal of all civilized world of
all people who speak about rule of law
about Justice about international law
that people who are responsible of this
of all the people
who is responsible of crime of
aggression who just came to the neighbor
State so just take the land and kill the
people actually they should be punished
I think it's very important that often
such situation in
in Georgia in Syria now we have so huge
and aggressive and brutal war in Ukraine
maybe it's time to not only to stop this
war not only to punish people who are
responsible but actually to prevent such
situation in the future Ukraine's Chief
prosecutor Terry I wonder did you get a
sense how this investigation compares to
other war crimes trials
well certainly and there are multiple
investigations at different levels in
different jurisdictions and that was so
what was so remarkable about today here
at Euro just a press conference with
with multiple prosecutors all working on
the same investigation all trying to
bring Russian President Vladimir Putin
and his henchmen the people around him
who are making these decisions every day
to kill ukrainians and and and to maim
them and to to ruin their cities that
they are eventually brought to Justice
and that's what the prosecutor was
talking about how every day she's going
out in gathering evidence from scenes
that continued to be you know in the
middle of a war zone so it will take
time and it is difficult and you know
this will this will definitely slow down
some of the investigation from some of
the worst scenes that you saw there in
that piece but they are all determined
to do this on various levels at the
local level in Ukraine at the
international criminal court in various
European capitals which have joined
joined this joint investigation so we're
going to see a lot of prosecutions in a
lot of different jurisdictions a lot of
different courts
just just quickly Terry even with that
cooperation even with that determination
how hard is it going to be to hold
alleged war criminals accountable here
to prove war crimes to prove client
atrocity crimes genocide as one of the
most difficult it takes years even
decades as we've seen at the
international criminal court but Ukraine
has already shown is going to move ahead
quickly there's already been some
prosecutions some convictions of people
who have been who have fired on
civilians killed civilians on the ground
there in Ukraine so I think it will be
step by step up to the highest highest
level of war crimes but Ukraine has
already made a lot of progress and is
moving very quickly Terry Schultz in The
Hague thank you
we are now joined by our regular
military analyst Frank ledwich in uh
from Oxford in the UK Frank the fight
foresee ever the Nets has been described
as a Race Against Time for the Kremlin
why the rush
well good morning gerhardt Russia is
still believe it or not a peacetime Army
so their Manning situation is of a
peacetime uh is a peacetime Army so
they're cut add to that the fact that
they're caught out by corruption
casualties and a lack of morale they
cannot sustain the momentum very much
longer now to be fair to the Russian
army that they've gone on so long at
such intensity is a real credit but they
simply cannot sustain that add into that
the factor of some Western weapons
getting through then you have if not a
time limit then you have
an operational limit on what can be
achieved for what amounts to frankly a
very limited success So speaking about
Western weapons deliveries as we heard
in that report earlier a U.S President
Biden appears to have put a damper on
Ukrainian hopes of getting heavier
weapons soon saying Washington will not
deliver long-range rocket systems what
do you make of that and how big of a
blow is this for Ukraine
get hot we can compare this to the migs
decision back in February only this is
far more important this is an artillery
War the only chance ukrainians have of
holding the Russians back is by matching
them in artillery and they're unlikely
to be able to do that without those
Western supplies the long-range rocket
systems are absolutely critical for the
ukrainians to be able to challenge
Russian supply lines this is a political
not a military decision
and as a political decision
it's it's deeply flawed the idea that
there's a difference implied in Biden's
quote there that we've heard before
between defensive and offensive weapons
is absolutely false this is a decision
that's going to cost lives and cost land
for the ukrainians which they'll have to
spend in even greater quantities to
retake the land they're gonna they're
gonna lose it's a deeply short-sighted
decision
you just said that this is an artillery
War but it seems to me that one of the
more overlooked aspects of the fighting
is the naval front the fight for sea
Lanes has become increasingly important
though for Kiev hasn't it
foreign
yes it has and we've heard little
flashes of this of course with this
sinking of the muskvar and the various
battles for snake island in the last few
weeks which the ukrainians seemed to
have lost the Russians have taken the
island not surprisingly but all those
battles the mosque of our Snake Island
the attacks on Russian frigates and so
forth and other Patrol boats they're all
in support of the idea of taking back
are at least challenging for control of
those sea legs now Deutsche Valley
yesterday is one of very few agencies
I'm really good credit for this to point
out that Lithuania which has always been
very forward-leaning in this war has
proposed that at least NATO or probably
more workably an International Coalition
Convoy vehicles in and out of the port
of Odessa now the reason for that is
military obviously it's a challenge for
that control but that's secondary here's
the political problem Ukraine is looking
at a situation where if it fails to
provide that entry to the Sea it's a
Mercantile Nation it's looking at being
a landlocked
state which cannot get its exports
particularly food out and a landlocked
failing state with a big army in the
medium term is not viable it's not
viable for itself and it's not viable of
course for Europe any form of European
Security in the longer term it's
absolutely vitalist Admiral stavridis
who used to be Sabrina Allied Commander
in Europe said that this was just as
important as Western supplies coming in
from the West this being
forcing an entry or supporting an entry
into Odessa and I think over the next
few weeks what we're going to see is
that front the naval front becoming ever
more important to get hot
our military analyst Frank ledwich there
thank you Frank
thank you gerhardt